what annoys you besides me I'm annoyed
by a great many things the wind market
boy oh [ __ ] me tape y'all there
excuse me sir may I take your order
please
pretty pretty please may I take your
order
oh oh we all may see oh yeah why is he
thrusting into the ground
dude stop oh wow yeah yeah this good for
lumbar support oh I can walk with my
human legs oh I can try to not spill my
human coffee
let me just thrust upwards hello sir can
I show you to your tablet oh well it is
a predicament tooth gimme fuel gimme
fire gimme that which I desire let's go
because I hear a pot oh oh that is Rob
hi Rob how you doing Rob well we're
gonna have ourselves a good old time
when we're fighting together together
forever you can't run away from your
fate Robbie Rob did I kill him no yes
yeah
do you have a happy place and can I see
it
I was once given the name Shu he was us
I'm sure lotion keeps your skins the
grundle on that jar of mayo is not okay
but I forgot my apartment was an armpit
so I was screwed what Oh God Oh someone
call jacksepticeye this is getting hot
in here you're not into my banana suits
how about this oh you should know it's
more shine scared let me show you here
we go let's go hammer time new twerk
okay I'm good with that
oh yeah oh yeah oh Marky likes
disrespected a well-known youtuber you
like that's that's not allowed come on
don't laugh at me you wouldn't
Oh
there no Angela who would you love
but
thanks for watching
all other videos in this compilation are
available in the description so check
them out and if you'd like to see more
in the future please leave a like to let
me know if you enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see more on a daily basis
please subscribe today or if you're
already subscribed share this video with
a friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye